My name is Manoj Badale.
I guess I'm what you would call a serial entrepreneur.
I was born in India but grew up in this country when my parents moved here.
And in my experience, having had the benefit of traveling around the world quite a lot,...
...the UK and Brits and British society are pretty tolerant.
And I think without that tolerance I perhaps wouldn't have gotten the opportunities I got,...
...whether they were university or school or sports-related,...
...and then ultimately business-related.
The reason I'm here tonight in the heart of the British Establishment in London is...
...because I'm giving a talk to a collection of young British and Indian entrepreneurs.
The shared history between Britain and South Asia in particular is extraordinarily powerful.
What I'm going to talk to them a bit about is the realities of doing business in India.
I started my career in the rather formal world.
We've got a collection of successful entrepreneurs and a collection of early stage entrepreneurs,...
...people hopefully trying to get a few pearls of wisdom from people that have got the battle scars.
I think in terms of what their expectations are,...
...they're probably looking forward to hearing about our recent experiences in the world of cricket.
Of course, cricket was something that was actually invented in this country.
People are often surprised to find out that I actually personally prefer Test cricket to Twenty20.
But I was always amazed at just how passionate the Indian market is about the game of cricket.
And you didn't need to be a rocket scientist to sort of know that at some point Twenty20 would become huge in India.
We took a British concept, "Pop Idol," and applied it to a cricket market.
We created a television show called "Cricket Star."
Then when the Indian Premier League came along,...
He's going for it,...
...he's found a gap,...
...Rajasthan Royals win!
...that's when we acquired the Jaipur franchise which is now a well-known brand, the Rajasthan Royals.
Get down, you're ready! Brilliant!
We tried to create a thing called the Champions League. The television rights for the Champions League in 2008,...
...got sold for 1.6 billion dollars for ten years.
But the two things that have always kept me going are if you're more innovative than your competition...
...and you're more agile than your competition, you've always got a chance.
There's a rebalancing of world cricket.
For Britain and British companies to really seize on the potential that South Asia offers, there needs to be an acceptance that,...
..you know, the balance of power is changing economically.
But I think the rise of Asia creates huge opportunities for businesses in the UK because of our shared history.
And it's a real asset for entrepreneurs who have the ability to straddle both markets, whether it's a product...
...or a platform that you've built for America, or built for Asia, or built for Europe.
In many respects, the UK is the perfect place to launch a business for any of those markets.
In terms of raising capital, this is the center of the world's financial services.
Access to talent, you know, we've got some of the best educational institutes in this country, many of whom encourage entrepreneurship.
So, if you are an Indian living in the UK and you are thinking about starting a business,...
...you're sort of crazy not to look at the potential that you get.
The potential asset you get from the connectedness of the UK, with the fact that a quarter of the world's population...
...is resident in a market that you have a cultural sensitivity around.
The link for me is that if you want to be an entrepreneur,...
...if you want to build your own businesses, you've got everything you need in this country.